the new june movie is a spectacular
cinematic experience that's vastly
different to david lynch's vividly weird
take on the original story by frank
herbert yippie kai movie lovers i'm jan
and in this video i'm explaining the
spiciest differences between denis
villeneuve's june and the 80s cult movie
lynch and veal nerve's films are worlds
apart when it comes to the villainous
characters of baron vladimir hakonen and
his nephew rabban aka the beast once
you've seen the 1984 version played with
maniacally ott gusto by kenneth mcmillan
who's covered in grotesque prosthetic
makeup and zooms through the air it's
not something you're ever likely to
forget his eye
then vladimir conan who encompasses his
doom stellen skarsgard gives a more
subtle less caricatured take on the
character making him memorable more for
his quietly menacing manner than his
gruesome cartoonish ways like the
original film even how he rises into the
air feels more ominous than the
exaggerated zoomy way it happens in
lynch's movie for veal nerve skarsgard's
eyes are the key to his frightening
performance as you feel the barons
always thinking tense and calculating
deep inside the first time we see him
he's hidden by steam giving the scene a
really atmospheric feel and reminding me
of the shadowy scenes of marlon brando's
colonel kurtz and apocalypse now as well
as the helmetless darth vader dave
bautista is back working with vel nerve
again after blade runner 2049 and
thankfully his interpretation of the
intimidating robin is much less
theatrical and sweaty than the 80s film
so far robin and his uncle play a
relatively small part in vielner's
cinematic vision of herbert's source
material more on that later as for the
baron's younger nephew fade there's no
sign of him at all at the moment i do
wonder if he'll pop up in part two
though and it would certainly be
interesting to see who veal nerve would
cast compared to the mad-eyed
over-acting of sting in lynch's film
despite june's dangerous dog-eat-dog
world there's one creature that seems
pretty much safe at all times and that's
the house of tradies pug whether sitting
patiently at home traveling through
space or venturing into battle the cute
royal canine always seems pretty chill
even if his presence in the film seems a
bizarre choice for a grand space opera
aiming to be star wars for grown-ups as
princess ireland actress virginia madsen
called it though we may never know
exactly why lynch made this weirdly
memorable and often beloved addition to
the world of june it may have something
to do with this particular breed's long
association with emperor's royalty and
the upper echelons of society from
ancient china to renaissance europe and
beyond
understandably though sadly for some
fans there are no pooches present in
vielner's version however the director
has made his own strange new addition
with a creepy giant spider creature with
uncanny humanoid features such as hands
at the ends of its legs the harkonnen
pet is listed in the movie's credits as
a human spider proxy and the creature's
performer is melena siddharova a
choreographer who came up with the
famous spider dance you might have seen
on youtube the spider creature appears
to understand human communication as it
responds to the benny jesuit reverend
mother when she orders it to leave the
room and this has led many fans to
speculate that the harkonnens turned dr
ue's wife into the spider it's a
plausible theory given that in the
original source material her fate was
never known although spoiler warning now
for character fates in june 2021 going
forward the baron implies that uh's wife
was dead at the time he kills the doctor
i said i'd set her free that you could
join her so join her the character of
duncan idaho played by jason momoa is
hugely improved in vlnerv's version
getting more screen time and his
relationship with paul is better
developed than in lynch's movie where
the two characters share just a couple
of scenes veal nervous described his
duncan as a kind of big brother
character who paul idolizes momoa's
duncan also gets an epic fight scene
where he sacrifices himself to take down
a slew sardikar warriors to buy time for
paul jessica and kynes to escape and
it's a pretty badass moment when he
pulls a sword out of his chest and takes
out another bunch of baddies before
eventually keeling over duncan's death
in lynch's movie is much more
anti-climactic with a projectile slowly
penetrating his defensive shield and
those holtzman energy shields were one
of the oddest things in the 80s movie
with the roblox like polygon shapes
surrounding a character making scenes
such as gurney and paul's fight training
just a mass of blurry forms facing off
them piling on top of each other
thankfully special effects have
massively improved since then and the
personal shields in 2021's movie are
much smoother and less flurry so you can
still see the characters clearly enough
kyle mclaughlin didn't do a bad job as
paul given the material he had to work
with especially all those endless
internal monologues he and several of
the other actors were forced to bring to
life however timothy chalamet's pool and
his past becoming the super being known
as a quizatz hadorak is much better
developed first of all although chalamet
was in his early 20s when filming paul
is around 15 to 16 in the original book
and the actor plays the part of a
somewhat inexperienced teenager thrust
into a deadly world of political
maneuverings much more convincingly than
in lynch's movie considering that
originally it's supposed to be a
coming-of-age story lynch's paul feels
much more like the man in his twenties
that the actor was at the time and too
self-assured also the way that velner
foreshadows paul's connection to arrakis
is teased more elegantly for starters
paul's visions of june and his future
there are clearer more nuanced and
detailed than lynch's more cryptic
clunky visions also veal nerve has added
more depth to scenes such as a sandworm
attack on the crawler in the new movie
as paul gets out of the ornithopter he
becomes entranced by the desert while
hearing mysterious voices chanting in
lynch's film paul never gets off the
ship and instead simply gets a little
intoxicated by the smell of the spice
the men bring in with them spice pure
unrefined
spice the look of vielner's worms is
also quite different and the director
explained to empire magazine that it
took over a year to come up with every
little detail that would make such a
beast possible from the texture of its
skin to the way the mouth opens to the
system it uses to eat its food in the
sand and to find the perfect shape that
looked prehistoric enough overall the
new sand worms seem even larger than
lynch's version which was more closely
based on the original designs by the
book's illustrator with its distinctive
three-lobed mouth
something we didn't get much of in the
2021 movie was worm riding with only a
small moment at the end where paul sees
a freman riding a worm in the distance
there's your power in lynch's film paul
memorably rides a worm and the creatures
are used as part of the fremen
resistance and attacks on the harkonnen
occupiers because this happens in the
latter part of the story it's safe to
say that we can look forward to timothy
chalamet riding a giant worm in the
sequel while lynch's film opens with the
emperor's daughter introducing us to the
world field nerve gives charney the job
of briefly being our guide to arrakis
given her prominent placing in the
movie's marketing you'd be forgiven for
thinking that zendaya must have quite a
substantial role but that's not the case
in fact her screen time consists mostly
of brief glimpses in paul's visions
until near the end of the film where she
and paul finally meet and she gets a bit
of real dialogue indeed her words are
the final ones we hear in the movie this
is only the beginning although zendaya
spent only four days filming for part
one in part two her character will have
a much larger more important place in
the story which i'm looking forward to
as she's a talented actress as for sean
young though lynch does cover the whole
book she's still only a very small part
of a much bigger movie and doesn't get
any especially interesting dialogue to
craft a truly memorable part with
when it comes to paul's mother lady
jessica velner has built up her role
compared to francesca anisa's version
giving her more time training and
defending her son rebecca ferguson is
perfectly cast bringing the delicate mix
of power vulnerability and mystery
that's required for her character whose
role encompasses parent partner and
member of the formidable and influential
benny jesuit who have the commanding
power of the voice which doubtless
inspired the jedi mind tricks of star
wars another character who gets more
screen time in the new movie is dr kinds
and compared to max von siddow in
lynch's movie sharon duncan brewster
goes out heroically exacting revenge on
the colonisers ravaging her planet i
serve only one master his name is
sometimes lynch's june feels more like a
collective hallucination or weird fever
dream that i had rather than a film i
actually watched it's frequent wacky
visuals and garish aesthetic certainly
give it a very distinctive look which
has its fans the latest film's look
however is wildly different more david
lean specifically lawrence varabia than
david lynch with touches of apocalypse
now vilnerv's own arrival and
cinematographer greg fraser's rogue one
there's plenty of lavish sweeping vistas
and arresting visuals but the director
never loses a sense of what really
matters his characters and the film's
muted more natural looking tones make
its pops of color stand out but in a
grounded more realistic way
trying to pack the whole of frank
herbert's expansive sci-fi novel into a
single film did not work out well for
david lynch the movie ended up heavy on
melodrama and overloaded with plot and
masses of expositionary dialogue not
only did it perform poorly at the box
office but it also was critically mauled
with reviewers calling it
incomprehensible stupefyingly dull and
disorderly and the worst movie of the
year even lynch himself disowned the
film and viewed it as a failure citing
his lack of artistic freedom making him
at the opposite end of the spectrum
denivil nerve says he's never felt such
deep joy or gratitude watching one of
his movies as he has done with june
vilnerv actually refused to adapt the
novel unless the story was split over
more than one film as the world was too
complex so the new movie brings to life
roughly half the book building its world
and introducing its concepts characters
cultures and planets though this does
mean the ending's a bit less satisfying
than you might like the sequel will
cover the rest while for vl nerve part 1
is like an appetizer part 2 is the main
meal an insane playground that will
allow him to go berserk and really
create and as if that's not enough the
director has even said that he'd like to
make a third film adapting the second
book in the june saga messiah i love the
overall epic feel of vielner's doom but
what do you think and if you've seen
both movies which do you prefer let me
know in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this then a thumbs up and a
share are hugely appreciated you can tap
here to discover all the epic easter
eggs and details you might have missed
in squid game or tap right for something
else you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time yippee
kai movie lovers